la parole est à notre collègue marc
laménie pour le groupe l'est républicain
mais la parole mon cher collègue merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mais mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
il ya un an des jeux les professions
réglementées étaient dans la rue dans un
mouvement de très grande ampleur
totalement inédit dans notre pays
plusieurs semaines de manifestations
notaire voka huissiers des filets contre
le projet de loi macron exaspérés par
les mauvaises manières qu'il aurait fait
nos professions ont été insultés
secondes et il rien ne s'est arrangé
pour eux cette année son nouveau les
professions du droit qui sont dans l'est
dans la rue les policiers il ya quinze
jours les avocats la semaine dernière
puis les personnels pénitentiaires qui
protestent place vendôme
depuis trois semaines déjà les avocats
manifestent durement 156 barreaux en
grève de l'aide juridictionnelle dont 93
en grève générale là encore du jamais vu
il se passe quelque chose de sérieux de
très grave
une justice du 21ème siècle qui veut se
construire sur de telles bases ça
interpelle
monsieur le ministre quand peut-on
espérer que tous ces désordres c seront
situation bien contraire à la recherche
d'une société apaisée tant vantée en
haut lieu
pouvez-vous nous informer sur l'accord
intervenu en fin hier avec les avocats
ainsi que des perspectives pour les
personnels pénitentiaires jour merci
merci sur le guen
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs la mini jeux répondent de
façon un peu contradictoire dans votre
question avec celle de votre collègue
précédemment il se désolait que nous
n'allions pas assez dans les réformes et
vous vous trouvez que nous en faisons
beaucoup trop ça fait partie
effectivement des ambiguïtés sur lequel
l'opposition devra peut être relever un
certain nombre
deux questions bon s'agissant des
avocats votre question effectivement
vient un petit peu peut-être de façon
tardive puisque comme vous l'avez noté à
la fin de votre question il ya
aujourd'hui un accord entre la
chancellerie et les avocats sur lequel
je vais vous donner s'agissant d'un
élément fondamental qui ne concerne pas
que les professionnels du droit mais au
contraire les justiciables à savoir la
question de l'aide juridictionnelle qui
est quand même un des éléments majeurs
des questions d'égalité d'accès au droit
dans notre pays c'est donc ce
gouvernement s'est attaqué à cette
question et le sol de plus 15 ans la
réforme comporte aujourd'hui trois
objectifs prioritaires le relèvement du
plafond de ressources permettant l'accès
aux justiciables à l'aide
juridictionnelle
l'augmentation la rétribution des
avocats qui n'a pas été relevé depuis
2007 monsieur le sénateur la
pérennisation du final du financement de
l'aide juridictionnelle
il a été donc décidé conjointement avec
la profession que la première étape de
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme élaboré
en concertation
les magistrats les greffiers les
huissiers de justice serait
l'augmentation de la rétribution des
avocats par un relèvement de l'unité de
valeur de 12,6 pour cent en moyenne sans
modification du barème les autres
éléments de la réforme auquel la
profession souscrit en particulier la
mise en place au niveau de chaque
barreau et tribunal de grande instance
d'une contractualisation complémentaires
seront mis en place de façon progressive
de façon à permettre la convergence des
trois montants d'unités de valeur vers
une unité de valeur donc aucune voilà
éclairé monsieur le sénateur et donc je
vous remercie monsieur la mini merci
monsieur le ministre
cependant la politique pénale
saurait-elle d'une certaine manière
devenu un marqueur de gauche au
détriment d'une vraie justice
l'insuccès de la contrainte pénale est
flagrant d'une certaine manière et
concernant la réforme de la justice des
mineurs
son efficacité sera à la hauteur de la
fermeté qu'il l'accompagnerait
quant à la prison vous avez
malheureusement souvent dénoncé son
mauvais état sont pourtant y remédier le
peuple français souhaite réellement et
veut une justice utile je remercie
merci